hello Doug Walker here uh Rob 'less as
you can see okay he did not get a chance
to see gravity this week so I will do
this alone but on top of that I am also
going to let you know a few things about
sibling rivalry here first of all two
things one if you're wondering why you
haven't seen that many around same
reason haven't seen that made bum
reviews around just there's been no big
interesting movies the past few weeks
there's sort of a dead summer and and
not that many interesting flicks but you
know some real big ones are coming up so
we'll definitely address those and then
the other reason is we were talking cuz
what we found out with doing the new
nostalgia critics that if it's something
were like the movie that we're reviewing
falls on a weekend where I'm doing like
an editorial that's fine but movie big
movies keep coming out every week
obviously so they fall on weeks that I'm
gonna be editing a lot and still wanna
get bum review out and sibling rivalry
so we're discussing like okay well what
do we want to do because we we can't do
Bo and I don't have time to do both in
terms of like a big sort of production
with sibling rivalry with a set and
editing and everything so we're like we
have to give a one bump review or the
sibling rivalry and I really like doing
the bum reviews but then brought brought
up a good point he says well why don't
we just do view our style while we just
do sort of we what we've been doing
actually majority of the time we'll just
do it without the set and without all
the bells and whistles and people seem
to like that fine so we're gonna keep
doing it we're gonna keep doing sibling
rivalry we're just gonna keep it simple
and you know just we can always make it
just put a camera in front of us and
talk we're good at that so you'll still
see those coming it would just won't
have all the bells and whistles like
what you saw with the the last moment
the Despicable Me 1 but we'll still make
good use of that set don't worry a lot
of that stuff is going to the Game Show
now so don't worry about that so yeah
just a heads up sibling rivalry is still
going on it's just gonna be actually sir
like what you've seen before it's just
very downplayed but people seem to like
that they're like well we're just
chatting about movies so that's what
you'll get with that said this is
gravity saw this
IMX and 3d and males like glad I did
that we came in and we sat like we came
in like a half hour early and like
theater was already packed by shit so of
course what's left like the second from
the front row okay let's do it we still
got a center see do you know that's nice
but it's second from the front row on
the friggin IMAX like the best seat you
could have had in the house for that
movie because this is a film all the
stuff you're hearing about it in terms
of like how breathtaking a lot of it is
really is true if you see this on IMAX
and 3d and actually sit close you feel
like you're in fucking space it's just
unbelievable how much this creates this
atmosphere and how much you just feel
like you're with these astronauts um and
for it take that out of it how how's the
rest of the film for the first maybe 40
minutes for me anyway I kind of forgot I
was watching a film I was just in it I
was just in space with these people and
it's shot in a way where it's very
flowing it's very close to these people
they try to very much capture their
point of view and it's very much an
experience and Sandra Bullock sir plays
the every woman up there of trying to
get back home George Clooney plays or
the supportive astronaut trying to help
and astronaut number three dies I don't
think I'm giving anything it's like you
can't know going in Oh who's that guy we
can't really see a close-up of his face
at all well he's dead so I don't think
that's any big reveal and it's really
amazing like I said the first 40 minutes
you really feel like you're just you're
in this play sure with the astronauts
and it's it's really unbelievable after
that you sort of start to become more
aware of your seat and that you're in a
theater and the dialogue gets a little
bit more movie ish and the situation's
get a little bit more movie ish but it's
still good movie it's it's done well so
I'm not gonna fall to at all like oh
should be this unbelievable experience
all the way through it's like no the
fact that they could get the first 40
minutes where I just feel like I'm in
frigging space I mean good god there's
people now paying to go into space it's
like just pay to see gravity in the
front row with 3d glasses it's like it
practically feels like the same thing so
it's it's very very impressive um and
like I said I think the point where she
starts to get eyed I'll try not to give
too much away but but there's a point
where they're saying you got to get to a
stage Space Station and she does get to
it
and I don't think I'm giving away too
much Trent that's not like the ending at
all don't worry
um I think around that point though use
you sir start to say to yourself how
many friggin things can go wrong
at first you kind of get it cuz it's
like you're just you're alone in space
you're in the stars you have this one
thing giving you oxygen and everything
is so sensitive one move and you can be
floating out there forever so you get it
you grasp it very quickly but then when
you get to the space station kind of
from then on it becomes a little the
universe hate Sandra Bullock you know
just everything is trying to fucking
destroy her and you become more aware of
that and like I said it's it's a
survival flick and there's a lot of
survive ease rebirth metaphors and stuff
um well you know they're still fine and
it's just but you become more aware
where it used to be while I'm up here
with these people you suddenly start to
go okay what's going to attack now
what's going to you know try to fuck
things up but like I said that that's
the nature of the movie I think it just
did the first 40 minutes or so so
unbelievably well that when it gets to
the part that oh now we're in a good
movie as opposed to an experience you
you for me anyway I could notice it but
I still really enjoyed it the dialogue
near the end gets again a little movie
ish um you know it's it's if for example
there's this one part that felt very
real Sandra Bullock who I'm not usually
a fan of but does very good in here like
I said she sort of
plays the every woman up there trying to
fight for her life and that for example
there's a scene where she gets like some
tower radio reception of like someone
from Earth or something and it's like an
Asian prison she can't understand but
has like dogs and a baby and you can
tell she just starts to crack a little
bit and starts to be like you know hey
keep keep get the dogs a louder casing
that while they that'd be nice into a
bark bark
if you were to read then the script
you'd be like the hell what the hell is
this but again in this environment that
they've created and the situation that
they've created you buy it and you sir
say okay I get why she's doing this but
then serve in other scenes she's sort of
making what I call the castaway speech
you know and I'm I'm gonna do this
because I can because I have a life
worth living now as and I feel you don't
really need that and I know like it's
totally possible for a say in that
situation would say this kind of stuff
but it's more possible in movies you
know it's are happens more in movies so
it's it still works okay um I think if I
have one other I don't want to say like
it's a downside but again maybe a hint
distracting is that George Clooney's a
little too fucking charming watching
this there's just anti-gay he's supposed
to be sort of like you know the callback
to hey focus you do your job let's you
know survive let's get out of here and
stuff but I mean this is guy ever break
a sweat does this guy ever get concerned
about anything everything he does it's
just you know with a cool little smile
and you know yeah of course it and it's
I get it I know he's supposed to be the
calm Center he's supposed to be the
thing that calms her down and calmed us
down but he's a little too friggin
charming in my opinion he still does
good though I mean he's he's totally
passable um by every time I saw him I
saw George Clooney there was never a
time I'm like oh I'm looking at this
astronaut who has this light now it's
always George Clooney Sandra Bullock I
saw you know
someone really trying to survive really
trying to you know do everything she can
to get back home and I really bought it
and like I said for someone that hasn't
been a huge senator Bullock fan like I
don't hate or anything I just haven't
gotten into her stuff uh I was impressed
by this I thought she did a pretty good
job even during the Hokey moments I
thought you know with the hokey dialogue
she she pulls it off pretty good uh so
yeah I say people who would not like it
I would probably say anyone looking for
like twists in turns or a lot of
character development this is not that
kind of film this is very much an
experienced movie so I don't want to say
like 2001 cuz there's not as many like
you know whatever it did there's not
quite as much like symbolism and though
there is but you don't even if you don't
acknowledge the symbolism you can follow
the story fine we're in 2000 was like
the symbolism takes over the story and
you know which is I love 2001 but it's
definitely an experience movie it wants
to it doesn't dive into these people's
lives too much because they want to make
it feel like you're this person up in
space and they do a nice balance it's
not they're not totally blank slates
they still do have backstories they're
very cleverly very cleverly shown you
know they talk about it's a sir keep
their sanity and so forth so it's it's a
good balance but I would say if you're
looking for like wow like this was such
an incredible story that every second
threw in a new twist a new turn
something you never thought of it no
it's it's people in space trying to get
back home I mean that's all it is but
it's done very much trying to make it
feel like you are in space and the 3d is
very good and the effects are very good
the cinematography is very good even
though I know it's mostly shooting
whatever computers these angles are
still very well calculated and
thought-out like the opening shot has to
be like 15 minutes long without an edit
and like I say you just feel like you're
flying around with these astronauts it's
very very well handled
I say people who would like it anyone
looking to feel like you're in space
looking to feel like you know you're
going to be in that you won't be up
there it is kind of a heart-pounding
film but it's not to a point a Lightfoot
this way it's not a film where all
you're looking at is Clooney and Bullock
just floating against stars it's not
that there are things to get to there
are obstacles to overcome so it's not
just looking at stars so for anyone sort
of afraid of that because island mates
are going in I was kind of like I don't
know like how real is this uh it is
suspenseful and it is kind of
claustrophobic but probably not in the
way you're thinking cuz the trailers
don't show that much it's not just them
floating against black you almost always
can see earth you can you know pick a
point you know that's I okay the side up
this side down you know and so forth so
it's not quite that bad
which I don't know how to feel about
that cuz the part of me does say man if
they really want to scare the fuck out
of you just put them out in space the
whole time it just rely on that but
again I think a might get a little
boring though they could pull it off and
be I think that would just possibly be a
little too intense and when you know
where the story goes and what it's all
amounting to it that this was good and
there's a good way that they did it so
yeah if your start looking for a decent
suspense thriller that also relies very
heavily on this experience of being in
space I say it's a good flick to check
out it I think it's pretty well handled
so yeah that's about it a lot of big
movies coming up this this fall in this
winter outside chance looking at the
list I'm like wow like white Indies come
out in in summer so I'm excited I'm
excited to see new films coming out and
you'll see more sibling rivalry and
you'll see more bum reviews all that
good stuff so lots of good things coming
your way and we will see you there
take care